what is happening right now
you and i may never experience this
perfect storm ever again
ever again here's why here's why
eight and a half percent inflation
that's going to go to 10 percent
they're going to keep it raising
interest rates that's not a
possibility maybe they will i'm on a
goldman sachs my
investment banker flew out we were
having a meeting together my advisors
and they said they're going to raise the
rates the next uh four times the next 18
months okay so you know what's going to
happen with inflation do not be
surprised if we crack 10 or 12
some people are like that'll never
happen same people that's the gas prices
won't go to five dollars it's
record-breaking high ever in the history
of america today it's 443 ever okay
then you're going to market okay you see
what's going on with crypto a lot of
those crypto millionaires are sitting
around saying oh my gosh what if bitcoin
goes to 15 000 i've been sitting on this
for a while the nft people are starting
to realize if there's no utility it
means nothing
the people who came and made their money
they're going to do well those who don't
turn those characters into somebody
everyone's going to say [ __ ] i'm stuck
with all this other stuff
i know you don't want to hear that
because some of you own it but if you
buy one with utility you're going to be
fine okay the metal lance stuff
metaverse stuff that's gonna be around
this is where i'm going with this
america's divided but they're starting
to have common sense bill maher is
starting to sound like he's given common
sense today joe rogan sounds like common
sense today people who are not support
they're just kind of like talking today
everyone's sitting there saying this
stuff makes sense america went from
being so united during 9 11 to becoming
so divided during covet and now after
cove has gone on we're kind of looking
around saying man these people fooled us
that we don't like each other these
people convince us i'm not supposed to
like you because you're black you're
white you're hispanic dude i got no
problems with you this is the united
states of america i'm fired up right
this is what we are feeling today so
check this out watch what's about to
happen watch what's about to happen
they're going to raise rates four more
times i sat down leon cooper and i had
him on my podcast a month and a half ago
leon cooperman is warren buffett wrote
him a letter when he retired he's a
multi-multi-billionaire if you don't
know who he is
very very well respected when it comes
down to the warren buffett world
i'm on the podcast i say leon you've
been around the block for a while he's
around 80 years old what do you think is
going to happen the next 18 months he
said i see a market correction around 40
percent
i said how much forty percent
okay
what happens if there's a market
correction of forty percent let me tell
you what's going to happen
the six hundred thousand dollar houses
are going to be worth 400.
million dollar houses are going to be
worth 6 700
okay
because rates are going to go up six
months ago rates were three percent
at three percent
if you can only afford a three thousand
dollar a month payment
you can finance around seven hundred and
fifty thousand dollars
at five point three today
with only a three thousand dollar a
month payment you can only finance
around 550 today
remember people buy a house based on
what interest rates loan amount or
mortgage payment per month
per month three thousand six months ago
seven fifty three thousand today's 550.
did you understand what just happened
right there and it's just getting
started now some of you guys are saying
are you not supposed to like come on
you're supposed to lift us up i'm scared
shitless right now like what just
happened right now with this meeting hey
sean who is this guy right
this is the point this is the point
whoever goes
into this season most prepared most
urgent willing to recreate themselves
with a level of urgency you've never had
before you're going to come out of it
two to five years from now everyone's
going to say oh look at him
perfect timing that's how he got rich oh
look at her perfect timing that's how
they made their money no no no
this season people been ready for this
season everyone was saying two years ago
warren buffett
look at him
sitting on 60 billion dollars of cash
100 billion dollars of cap man has no
clue what he's doing he's completely
lost his philosophy
okay yeah he's lost what he's doing
he knows everything's going to go on
sale in the next 6 12 18 months and he's
going to buy everything on sale
brace for impact baby the next 12 24
months the best time in my lifetime
where the opportunity is so perfect to
create wealth for yourself
folks
this perfect storm
may not happen again next 40 years i
have nothing to sell you i don't have a
three program to register for this i
have i'm not that speaker that's gonna
sell you courses today there is zero
selling that's gonna go on today i don't
have an incentive of telling you this
news all i'm telling you is there's
gonna be many of you in this room who
leave who add an additional zero at
minimum if not two the next two to five
years some of you that only have
eighteen thousand dollars that eighteen
is going to be 1.8 million dollars five
years from now if you do it right that's
what's going to happen so hopefully if
you're ready i'll be excited for you now
let's get right into the message how
many guys are still not convinced you
ought to create video content be honest
it took me many many years to want to
create con how many guys are not
convinced you ought to create video
content raise your hand be honest if
you're not if you if you're convinced i
can leave guys if you're not everybody's
already in you're already going to
create your content okay well let me let
me sell it to you from a different angle
okay
this picture right here if we can go to
the first picture this picture right
here to you this picture means nothing
to me
this picture to the right is my dad
okay
to his left is his sister my auntie
to her left is my grandfather
to his left is my uncle johnny
and to the far left is my grandmother
rose okay
we call her rosa okay
i've never met the man in the middle my
grandpa i met all the other four i never
met my grandpa he was dead when i was
born would have loved to have met him
never met him
this picture here
is also my grandfather
the one on the left
is my dad's side when they got married
that's my grandfather whom i've never
met i got my height from that family
because my mother's side they're all
five feet tall
literally on my dad's side
six four six five and a mailman was
about six eight but for the most part
the height comes from my dad's side
right
to the right is my mom's dad
okay and my grandma that's my grandma my
grandpa okay in that picture i've met
them
when you look at these pictures you say
okay pat where are you going with this i
got a very simple question for you
how much money be honest on the dollar
amount what would you give
dollar wise
to get a hundred hours of content
of your grandparents and great
grandparents what would you pay
if all of a sudden elon musk invents
this new technology to go back to the
future and have a drone
follow your grandparents for a hundred
hours of footage to watch them what
would you pay for that scream at the
dollar a month somebody said priceless
what's that word to you
what's that word to you by the way how
many of you guys get emotional just
thinking about it see that gets me
emotional
that gets me emotional
because i've never met that man
i'd love to sit there as a 43 year old
man who's got four kids right now but
when i watch him
i'll be a
five-year-old grandson watching my
grandpa i never met before getting
emotional over 100 hours to say
that's where i get that from
oh my god that's me
that's where that comes from
that's sick
one day
your grandkids are gonna hope there's
content of you
so for some of you that are sitting
there saying why am i waiting to create
content the argument is over you're not
doing it for you to become famous you're
not doing it to make more money create
content because your grandkids are
hoping you produce content so they can
study you when you're no longer here
with us
does that make sense so now let's
continue
this is me in this picture okay when i
was six years old my teacher asked me a
question and said
what do you want to be when you grow up
i said i want to be a dad
he said you want to be a dad i said yeah
he says why you want to be a dad i said
i want to be a dad do you have a reason
for it i said i just want to be like my
dad when i grow up
that guy to the right he's my hero i'm
the one in the middle this is us in iran
my mother
my sister
myself looking like a little alien and
my dad okay
that's us that's what a middle eastern
family looks like 42 years ago okay
to you it's just another picture to me
i go to a street called kriamonejojet
i go to gem hospital where i was born
i go to bandar pahlavi which is port of
pallavi
i go to
parquez which is a park
i go to
8 o'clock at night i look through the
window glass i see my dad's head coming
up
because i saw him fourth floor and i
would run up to the door to hug my dad
that's what it means to me now
five years ago my dad comes up to me
says i got some good news
i said what's that
he said you won't believe this
i just found footage
old footage of when paulette was a euro
paul that's my sister
pull it at a year old running around
i'm like no way he says yeah i was so
excited he said why are you so excited i
said because if you have footage of
paulette paulette's six years older than
me that means when i was a year old the
camera must have been better so my
footage should be sick
he says
we didn't record anything of you
all right you're serious he says yeah i
said tell me this is like the moment
where you say yeah you know joking with
you no there's no joke seriously yeah
who the hell had the camera and they
didn't keep the camera for seven more
years that's all you needed we don't
have the camera i would have loved to
see me run and run there's zero footage
of me running around as a kid
the power of taking content even with
your kids if you have kids so now let's
continue
if you're gonna create content there's
three levels to creating content i'll go
from the lowest level to the highest
level you pick and choose which one of
these moves you number one it's fun
it's fun creating content
there's nothing like it you sit there
and go back to the old videos it's
entertaining till today the video i
watched the most
on my youtube channel is the vlogs i
used to do which was not something i
enjoy doing but there's one vlog that we
did when we went to the dinosaur museum
and in the middle of it my middle son
dylan who's got bo jackson's butt he's
got the he's eight years old like this
he's muscular and he wanted to meet bo
jackson so i rented out the dallas
cowboys stadium brought bo jackson and
they spent a bunch of time together for
like a couple hours right
and he's like this villain okay he runs
like this and he likes to always be
around to pull without a shirt on all
this other stuff
so
you know we're we're sitting there at
this dinosaur a museum in dallas
and all of a sudden we go across the
water creek and his shorts get wet his
shoes get wet his socks get when his
shirt gets wet now i know he doesn't
like this
so in the house he takes off all his
clothes
but i'm assuming like as a you know you
don't do that in front of people because
there's like a few hundred people there
dylan's like no i don't like water on my
clothes he starts taking his shorts off
he starts taking everything off i'm like
dylan you gotta keep no i don't you know
i don't like he's four years old do you
know i don't like water he takes
everything off
and we're walking around here in the
middle of the thing with my son
everyone's looking at me saying what
kind of a father i saw honestly he's not
gonna let me do it you're his father
he's not gonna let me make his i watch
that video i don't know a few hundred
times
because it's fun the second reason why
you ought to create content is fame and
money now if you're not somebody that
wants the fame and the accolades that
comes with it no problem some people are
driven by that if you want the money
that also comes with that because your
credibility goes up
eyeballs equals increasing your
credibility for the right reasons
there's many ways if you want to get
real eyeballs go on a flight sit right
behind tyson talk a bunch of crap he'll
punch you in the face you're going to
get plenty of eyeballs
if you want eyeballs go to a dave
chappelle show you know jump the stage
get bunch of people to beat you up and
then they're gonna do a story about you
can get eyeballs i'm talking the right
eyeballs and last but not least is
legacy
why you ought to create content
your future grandkids and great
grandkids are going to want to see it
now
how many guys here what do you say
legacy how many guys here ever get this
feeling that you feel like you were put
on this planet to do something big how
many guys really feel that way don't
just raise your hand to raise it how
many guys actually believe that how many
guys actually are like my life's been a
weird life i feel like i'm here to do
something big okay great
years ago i heard a message
from dudley rutherford a mentor of mine
this is 15 years ago
and he talked about the seven mountains
of influence to climb
and he explained which one that was the
toughest one
and he went through it he said pick one
of these mountains to go to the top to
make positive impact but i'm gonna tell
you which one's gonna be the toughest i
said what are the seven
he shows it to us
one is art entertainment and sports
to some of you you wanna create content
because you know a lot about how many
guys know a lot about sports how many
guys know a lot about sports and you
actually have good opinions about sports
yes or no okay that's one way to create
content how many guys know a lot about
art how many guys know a lot about nft
how many guys know a lot about baseball
cards how many guys know a lot about
collectibles how many guys know a lot
about collectible cars anybody knows
about things like that that is a form of
art right
the other one is business to make it to
the top
okay where you have influence the next
one is education
the next one is family then it's
government then it's media then it's
religion
faith
pick and choose no matter who you are in
this room
make your impact in one of these seven
pillars
the one he said that's the toughest one
to do
is media
so i'm sitting there listening to him
give this message i said you know what
i was uh i don't know what year this was
2007 i went to my uh pastor because i
was like trying to figure out what i'm
supposed to do my life and i go up there
and say hey you know i'm trying to
really figure out what to do my life
i'm making a lot of money i met the girl
i'm about to marry and things are going
really good for me i said do you think
maybe i'm supposed to be a pastor he
says listen there's a lot of things you
may be supposed to do being a pastor is
not one of them so don't even do that
that's not for you you go to business
now okay good man i got one of them out
this is great that's not me so i go to
the business side right the point is
pick one
and climb up
don't try to pick every single one of
them i chose my route which one it was
going to be for me by the way we're
having lunch right now with sean for a
few minutes
and i asked him a question about and i
told him about what's going on today
with america how many parents are
worried about sending their kids to
public school very weird time i said do
you realize how perfect of a time right
now it is
if i if i if i was somebody who was in
that world if i was a mother concerned
about sending my kids to public school
and i've been homeschooling for the last
three four five years do you know how
many questions there is for other
mothers and parents that want to know
what it's like to do homeschooling
10 struggles how many guys homeschool
your kids here raise your hand if you're
homeschooled okay people don't know you
think people know they don't know what
programs are seven programs used for
homeschooling okay six mistakes parents
make one homeschooling okay 15 ways to
team up with your neighbors for
homeschooling nine ways to save money
when you're homeschooling eight ways to
still get your kids involved in sports
while you're homeschooling there is a
massive market for that the next two to
five years someone's going to go out
there with this specific message get a
few million subscribers the next two
three four five years because people
want that message that's a part of
that's family and faith
that could be yours i can i can give you
50 more ideas like this there are so
many ways but pick your seven so now
why do you create content a few
different reasons let me get into it
influence
seo
positioning in a marketplace fame money
selfish reasons fun pranks laughter
impact therapy it's therapeutic to you
internal family maybe your own company i
have a complete separate youtube channel
for my insurance company that's all
private videos that are not public
rights there's internal family company
legacy there are different reasons pick
your reason now
forbe recently gave some statistics on
this did you know there are
over four or over 50 million content
creators today
on youtube instagram twitch
tick tock and other social media
platforms who didn't know that by the
way 50 million this is not 50 million
users
because there's billions of users
50 million who are creators now watch
this
did you know two million of them are
full-time and they earn six-figure
salary by creating content daily or
weekly
do you know what's two million that's a
lot of people
that's a lot of people to do two million
making six figures or more just creating
content
ninety percent of the video audio photo
text-based content consumed by today's
gen z
is created by individuals not
corporations
guys let me say this one more time
90 of the content consumed by jay z by
gen z not jay-z by gen z
probably jc2 by the way
90 of the content created by gen z
consumed by gen z is by social media
it's not it's individuals not
corporations do you know how big this is
because always remember the first time i
went on snapchat is because i was on
hawaii putting an event together 400 of
my executives one of my executives
kahindi his daughter phoebe sitting next
to me she's 14 years old at the time
she's a runway model now in new york
paris all over the place she's sitting
next to me saying mr bed david are you
on snapchat i said teach me she grabs my
phone teaches me about snapchat shows me
all the filters i get on snapchat
because i asked her a question what are
kids today which app are kids using
today in high school this was 10 years
ago i said you guys use facebook she
starts laughing
she knew before any of us knew that no
one's going to use facebook not for that
specific reason i said you use this to
use that no we use snapchat
if gen z is consuming content because of
individuals not corporations what are
you by the way what is everybody here
you're an individual guess what that's
opportunity right there so crazy
predictions number one
mr beast will be a billionaire
he'll be the first youtube billionaire
as a youtuber this kid's gonna be a
billionaire
these guys ryan's world anybody knows
who ryan's world is yes no they can be
billionaires by a bunch of different
ways
logan paul will one day be a president
laugh all you want he's going to be your
president one day
laugh all you want baby you'll be voting
for him one day
51
of you will be voting for him
you said it right
all right next
jake paul will be the next don king
do you question that you know how much
money he made last year he made 45
million last year he's one of the
highest paid athletes he's a youtuber
okay through youtube he cuts checks
saying come fight me we'll do this and
he's making money all over the place
right now brothers by the way joe rogan
media disrupter change the game
what he says people fear him by himself
his podcast gets 11 million views tucker
carlson gets 2.7 million views this guy
gets 11 million views on his podcast
elon musk power disrupter
he scared the hell out of everybody
corporations are you know the other day
when he announced what he announced on
twitter saying i'm convinced today if i
had to vote i can no longer see myself
voting as a democrat i see myself voting
as a a republican do you know the next
day a woman came out saying the fact
that he did something to her years ago
at spacex now we don't know this but
guess what america today is what america
is no longer about innocent till what
proving guilty we're living in the era
of
guilty until proven innocent
look at amber heard and johnny depp do
you guys know why johnny's suing her
how many guys have no clue why johnny
the episode will soon amber heard racion
if you have no clue
why he's suing her
can you guys tell the rest of the by the
way a lot of people's hands went up can
you tell everybody else why johnny depp
is soon amber hurt
defamation
she lost him his favorite position that
he played favorite character which is
who
jack sparrow he said i'll never play it
again 300 million i'll never play it
again elon musk
is pissing everybody off
and he knows how to use twitter
do you know who he's training to get
better at twitter guess who's the guy
that's behind him
jeff bezos he's teaching jeff bezos how
to use twitter last week jeff bezos got
his most liked tweet ever
did you guys hear what he said he called
out the president it was all over the
news because jeff bezos is sitting there
saying i may need to learn from this guy
because i may be good at making money
but i'm not a troll like he is and these
politicians are bullying me left and
right everyone's being trained
so don't be the one left behind let me
continue
so how about you what are you going to
be known for
what are you going to be known for and
by the way you know what you know when i
knew i was going to do something big
with my life when i no longer answered
this as a joke
when it wasn't like i'm going to be no
no boom
and everyone's like
and i'm like this
i'm not playing this is what's going to
happen to our life sat my family down 26
years old we came out of a
birthday christmas party wasn't too
happy about the way one of our relatives
talked to my dad sat everyone down i
said dad the world has no clue who you
are they're going to have to kill me the
world's going to know your last name
it's over and my sister is looking at me
in my life like i'm dad look at me
the world is going to know your last
name
they're going to know what the bed
davids are they're gonna have to kill me
but they're gonna know who you were i'm
gonna tell the world about how special
of a father you were no one talks my dad
like that ever again guys i'm a regular
guy nobody knew who i was
boom like this came over something
switch i wasn't the same ever again so
when you answer this and you're not
joking and you're serious the world's
going to believe you
do you understand what i just said right
there or no
and by the way don't be afraid when
people laugh at you and they say oh come
on yep that's what i'm going to do
that's what i'm going to do
this is who i'm going to be you make
that decision so now you're building two
brands today very simple personal
business
it's no longer building a business brand
it's you're building a personal brand
and you're building a business brand
the bigger the personal brand gets the
better your business does if you know
how to control it
the bigger your personal brand gets the
business takes advantage of it
let me ask you a question if tomorrow
elon musk leaves tesla
do you buy more tesla stock the next day
why not
what's tesla worth today
shy of a trillion dollars how many guys
drive a tesla here raise your hand if
you drive a tesla i look by the way look
at the hands real quick that's crazy
that's crazy why you buy how many of you
drive a tesla because of elon musk raise
your hand look at the hands look at the
hands look at the hands
what if you did not know who elon musk
was would you drive a tesla
this just validated my point
pay attention to your personal brand so
now developing your personal brand this
is me
that's me at 18 to the right when i was
wanting to be a bodybuilder i'm in the
military that's the kid
okay later on i had a vision
on what i wanted to do
i saw a guy like me a regular guy with a
1.8 gpa not from a wealthy family
changed his life because of capitalism i
said i'm going to show everybody else to
do the same as well we grew a small
insurance company with 66 agents to
we've licensed 35 we have 20 000 active
agents that's us at an event we had
right before covet with kobe bryant and
president bush this was two and a half
years ago we'll do an event in the next
two months at mgm we'll have 15 000
people there last year we did an event
at mgm with ten thousand people
sebastian manuscaka was opening up i had
mario lopez as our mc i had mike tyson
with smoking weed i had uh
who else do we have mickey jam nicki jam
opened it up concert it was an insane
event right this year we're having shaq
we're having kurt we have all this but
the point is we went from a small
insurance company to a bigger insurance
company you know how many people would
say the following what do you do pat
never once on my youtube channel if you
watch my youtube channel you will never
once see me say
i run an insurance company apply here to
be an agent with us not one video will
you ever find i kept the two brands
separate but what people in the industry
started saying is pat
you're running insurance yeah man i want
to be part of insurance boom my brand
elevated the insurance company followed
and then eventually the brand gets
bigger than you
where it's a standalone without you
that's the goal of where you want to be
with your company because that's where
the valuation goes up so then because of
this you write books you number one wall
street journal bestseller it's the
highest rank it's ever been with the
book because the brand keeps getting
bigger so the book comes out a year and
a half ago it's selling more copies
today than when it came out the first
month i don't know if you heard what i
just said the book is you know how books
typically come out it sells the most in
the first month
the book is selling more today year and
a half later two years later than when
the book came out two years ago
why the brand's gotten bigger as the
brand gets bigger all the opportunities
increase as well so now
content
comedy pranks politics dating how to men
women conspiracy history books you
choose
you can write you can do video you can
do audio i prefer video because video
turns into everything if you do video
you can be a podcast and you can have
somebody write it
video goes to everything audio doesn't
go to everything because audio can only
go to audio and text
text can only go text it doesn't go
video but video goes everywhere this is
why sean is hosting the event around
video so now you pick and choose your
topic let me kind of give you an idea of
what happened with some of the things
that we do so now how to increase your
own brand awareness
pr write articles easy you can do that
controversy how many guys are not
comfortable
taking controversial positions because
it may hurt your business plan raise
your hand
there may be a time where you can't do
it if you can't do it today don't and by
the way if that's not you don't do it
i'm very comfortable being controversial
but i don't recommend anybody being
controversial if it's not you're not if
you are controversial and you go to
sleep all night thinking about the video
and you can't go to sleep don't create
it but if it's your personality then go
at it you can't change that anyways
that's you right
game change your home run like one of
the things i did a few months ago this
was about a year ago on fourth of july i
made an announcement and i uh made a
video and the media called me i was on
all over tv i wanted to pay five million
dollars
to have president obama and president
trump sit face-to-face have a three-hour
conversation together two and a half
million dollars to the charity of
obama's choosing two and a half million
dollars to trump's uh
uh what do you call a charity of
choosing let's get to have a three-hour
conversation i'm willing to bet america
wants to see how united the two of you
are
are you up for it and i put five million
dollars on the line one side agreed the
other side didn't agree but guess what
everybody called
and everybody said hey let's get more
eyeballs behind it that sometimes you do
a certain home run shot that video right
the life of an entrepreneur 90 seconds
how many guys have seen it who's in life
of an entrepreneur in 90 seconds do you
know 10 years ago what it meant for
video to go viral if a video got 2
million views in 24 hours that was
considered viral you know what it is
today it's 10 million
you got to get 10 million and 24 hours
that thing within 24 hours got 10
million views
a week later 30 million views that video
has been shared on so many different
people it's got about a half a billion
views that one little video that with
the life of an entrepreneur you know how
much money we spend on that thirty one
hundred dollars you know how much
eyeballs we got
a lot more than that okay so you you
pick creative ways to get eyeballs out
there as well strategic partnerships
influencer marketing wow experiences
couple of things that we did as well
experiences your own brand that reads
bookshelf i had it custom made i would
do my videos and people would say man
can i get that read bookshelf that's a
really cool bookshelf man i love to get
that bookshelf well then do something
with your own language if reading is
your mo like i think today
the market is wide open for a book club
i think a real book club with real
reviews with somebody that reads real
books on a specific topic i think that's
a 7 million million subscriber channel
right if you are doing that but we did
that as a branding industry research
giveaways there's so many ways to do
things and then most important thing
i'll tell you guys when it comes down to
this for you to be thinking about
is who you choose
to
which community you choose to be a part
of
people used to always say well pat i
don't see you at all these other events
that everybody speaks that's intentional
why
i see myself with this community
if i'm watered down with everything
then i'm everybody and i'm i'm not
everybody i relate to this person
i'm trying to get into this community i
relate to joe rogan joe and i and i have
a friendship together okay when i go on
the podcast or we go to a fight together
we're having dinner together there's a
relationship
pick and choose which community you
eventually want to be a part of and find
your way in that direction does that
make sense to everybody don't try and by
the way you know who that community is
and what maybe for you is not for
somebody else pick and choose that
community and find a way to get into
that community because then
automatically the market's gonna brand
you with that community good bad or ugly
if it's you go for it next
business brand okay let me give you a
couple other things here
starters those who haven't started and
have no social media those who have some
subscribers those of you that already
have a platform with a million
subscribers i'll show you what a couple
things we did here's our formula on
coming up with ideas we sit we ideate
like today during lunch sean got an
example of how we ideate from id8 we
research
after we research we adjust
then we come up with the script and the
content and then there's a call to
action we put the video together
this exact formula is how we came up
with all our business videos okay every
one of them did you hear how i said the
single mother the mother that's going to
private uh public school that doesn't
want to go to publix for homeschooling
we came out with seven episodes together
how quickly we set those 15 points
that's how we come up with that content
right
so now this was our test step number one
on testing
we came up with a content called two
minutes with pat
i said i'm gonna do 100 videos two years
one video a week
we did two uh two years one video a week
only one video was two minutes every
other video was more than two minutes
eight minutes nine minutes 20 minutes
people would complain you're lying this
is not two minutes with pat okay this is
eight minutes with pat change the time
up right well we tested
then we got clear we got a vision with
valuetainment and then it became a niche
our niche was business and
entrepreneurship right this was specific
to what we did
and through these segments then came a
couple home runs that we hit we got
lucky nothing wrong with lucky then you
got to take a few timeouts we've taken
three timeouts so far
one of them we took at
100 000 subscribers one we took at 450
one we took out 2.9 million subscribers
and we're coming back to valuetainment
creating content next week every once in
a while you take the time out you come
back and say okay what's our next move
then you go to the next one so test step
number one what's next
test
vision identify niche get lucky take a
time out and repeat this process over
and over again so now we got many
different channels our main one's got
3.38 million subs our short clips got
275. the podcast we started has got 203
our valuetainment money's got 61 000
subs our russian valuetainment's got 290
000 subs it's all in russian our spanish
we just started got 12 and a half and
now we're creating content by recruiting
other people so you can do vlogs
how-to's interviews content partners
many different things and i can turn
them into reels there's so many
different ways one video goes into so
many different pieces of content now
we've done original series mafia states
of america 10 series documentary i don't
know if you guys seen that or not pair
felix a lot of different things but
here's the format so this is one way how
many guys do an actual podcast
how many actually do a podcast okay
podcast system is simple but you got to
stay consistent you don't do one this
weekend you do the next one seven weeks
from now you do it every week for it to
work so podcast we do an episode
with jordan peterson get 774 000 views
that's great
but then we do short clips that goes on
other channels this is a two-hour
interview but we got 15 short clips out
of it the 15 short clips got 9.1 million
views
itself the interview only got 774. the
short clips got 9.1 combined 9.9 million
at this point it's over 10 million views
so that is a system you do a long form
you hit up different topics you cut them
in different short clips and by the way
this is just youtube videos views this
is not tick tock this is not jordan
peterson putting on clips that he puts
on twitter all the time this is not
instagram or facebook you put everything
together it's about 35 million views i'm
purely giving you youtube data and what
does this pay i don't know 70 000
thousand dollars some of you guys know
the numbers better than i do on what
this pays that's what the adsense pays
with youtube now some of you are saying
well pat how long is going to take me to
get there it's gonna take a minute
we started in 2013. it's 20 to 20 22.
this is not like a one-year game plan
you're going on this is a 10-year run
that you're making a commitment to this
is not a one-year commitment if you're
trying to hope that you get lucky and a
video goes viral we didn't get any luck
for three and a half years
nothing happened for three and a half
years then boom something took off okay
and then reminders for content creators
more intentional content that's quality
equals more influence you're able to
control the narrative whatever the
market says you can control the
narrative by creating your own content
find the one word that works for you and
what doesn't collab collaborate
accordingly don't prostitute your brand
study your data show mistakes on
vulnerability focus and stay consistent
challenge people to question their views
know the difference between today and
evergreen content we have content that
gets views always we have content that
only gets views for 48 hours
certain like amber heard and uh uh
what's his name um
johnny depp no one's going to search for
that 10 years from now make sense these
are some of the things we've done to
create content having said that reminder
at the end as we're talking about which
you know mountain to climb pick and
choose your mountain take advantage of
the next two to five years that's coming
up put a goal in place to add an
additional zero minimum to your net
worth the next two to five years
[Music]